Шановний пане голову Шановні колеги
фракція європейської солідарності
сподівалася зараз почути слова вибачення
перед співголовою нашої фракції перед
колегою перед жінкою народним депутатам
Геращенко бо український народ зараз
демонструє Єдність і ми в цьому залі
маємо демонструвати Єдність і
відповідальність
сьогодні коли свято другої пречистої
коли
міжнародний день миру
маньяк диктатор виголосив своє бління
Я хочу розтлумачити що це означає що
змусило його це зробити Перше це єдність
і мужність українського народу друге це
мужність і героїзм Збройних Сил України
третя - це світова коаліція на підтримку
України яка демонструє це нашими
партнерами
четверте
безпорадність збройних сил Російської
Федерації яких перемололи збройні сили
України на території України в наших
операціях І сьогодні вони вимушені
мобілізувати зеків гвалтівників опущених
фізі теж сломалися нестить нових і вони
оголошують мобілізацію Ми впевнені в
тому що це також потужний меседж і для
росіян коли мають зрозуміти що це не
якась операція воєнна це повноцінна
війна за яку вони заплатили заплатять
партнери дайте більше зброї санкцій і
фінансування в Україні он вилучить Росію
зради безпеки НАТО приймить Україну
члени НАТО дайте план дій щодо членства
і Путін